what is your message to president putin
on russia's victory day
if it is the first message he definitely
want to celebrate
his victory day on the ukrainian
kiev in christchurch
and instead of that this is the
instead of the victory day this is a
defeat march
and which happened in moscow and this is
another evidence that putin is
completely crazy
he live in the absolutely
parallel world to a different universe
the different universe which
he said that he is waging
on the land belonging to himself
mr putin this is ukrainian land
and this is nothing to do you and we
hate you we do not wait in you do not
expect you
and point number two he said that in
reality he is opposing the nato
mr putin nato is for security of the
nato member states and they not oppose
you this is you who tried to attack
everybody including the nato states
and uh please stop to be crazy and with
the
third things this he said that this is
the
neo-nazi in ukraine
mr putin if you have
seen
what's doing your barbarian soldiers
this is even not the soldiers who rape
the
women who raped and killed
boys and girls children
who killed the ukrainian
civilians with the tight hands this is
you who
act exactly like nazis and
we ukrainian just deliver the
information that
the you should be should make you are
criminal and you make a crime against
humanity and we never forgive and we
never forget these crimes
it's a powerful message to send to putin
on an important day for russia and in
response your current president vladimir
zelinski recorded a video address
defiantly walking through the streets of
the capital
and the ukrainian resistance has been
impressive it's impressed you know
people across the globe and it certainly
struck a chord with vladimir putin can
you update us
on the resistance in your country
and where the major battles are at the
moment because vladimir putin
specifically addressed the people of the
donbass region in his address today
first of all putin wanna uh take ukraine
in a two and a half days
today we have two and a half months
and we ukrainian
surprised the world our armed forces and
i'm proud that it was created under my
presidency in year 2014
and we're
surprised the world stopped there as
putin's second biggest army in the world
and we surprised putin himself and with
that situation
i am confident i'm just returned from
mikolai from the south and during the
last week i was in kramator slavians in
donbass where putin pretended that he is
already captured no
this is uh definitely ukrainian
forces demonstrate a miracle and we're
ruining all the putin's scenario even in
mariupol we're putin many times declared
that it is already captured uh we our
brave soldiers is still keeping fighting
and
putin now
again killing the civilians killing the
victim and destroy completely the
civilian object and with that situation
i think that we putin tried to destroy
ukraine to destroy infrastructure object
oil
refinery ports airports and he think
that this is a lead to that ukraine
sometimes some days give up
please remember ukraine never give up
we stop you and we definitely need to
stop putin or even more to deputy nice
russia to deputy nice world and this is
the only way how we can stop it and
with this situation if you ask what we
need
for
implementing of our purposes definitely
ukrainian needs peace
and for peace
we need three things weapons
weapons
and weapons this is the shortest way to
the piece
petro poroshenko good to talk to you
here on sky news this afternoon thank
you so much for your time stay safe
thank you thank you